The last thing that we're going to take a look at in the demonstration is the aim node.
And I just want to show you a different way to control where our gun is pointing.
Now this might be useful if you want to be able to lock onto or track something, or essentially
if you always want something to be aiming at something else and not have to sort of manually
animate the rotation to account for that.
So to get this setup, the first thing I'm going to do is just bring our forward solve
out here a little bit and search for a sequence node.
And this is just so we can kind of split the logic into two flows and understand things
a bit more clearly.
So first we'll plug in all the logic that we had and then down here I'm going to search
for an aim node.
Now we're just getting a warning there because we haven't set anything up yet, but we have
connected the logic.
So by default, the thing that the aim node is looking for is a bone.
But what we're going to do is actually utilize the setup we have for these controls where
we've set the limits and it's already controlling our bones and actually aim the control instead.
And to make things a little bit more mechanically accurate, we're actually going to split the
rotation between these two controls so that as we move this sort of aim control around
that we're going to create in a moment.
Our turret will move up and down in this axis with this control and rotate the entire body
with this control.
So we're essentially splitting the yaw and the pitch rotations between the turret base
control and the main gun control.
So first we'll set up the turret base because that's going to be first in the chain of bones
essentially.
So if we select our turret base control and just press this arrow here, I'm just going
to disconnect it so they don't get any funky results until we've set it up properly.
I'm going to pop open the axis, the target, the target space and secondary here.
So under the axis for this bone, for this control rather, we need turret base to be minus
one in y and zero in x.
And then we need to be one in z for our target.
And our target space is going to be the control that we're going to create that will affect
these, the aim of these.
So we're going to create it from the main gun bone.
So if I select the main gun, press control N, we'll get a new control.
And I'm just going to call this cannon aim control.
And with this control, we want it to be out in front of the cannon so that we can move
it around and have it point towards it.
So what I'm going to do in just the x axis because that's the axis that our bone is pointing
and the axis that this gun is currently aiming is I'm just going to drag that out to some
distance in front of the actual mesh.
And under the scale, I'll just set it to 10.
And let's just change the color and perhaps even the shape, something like a wedge might
be cool.
And one thing I forgot to do there before I compiled is actually set the offset transforms
from this control's current position.
So that's why it popped back to its original location.
So if I drag that back out again, right click, set offset transforms from current.
When I compile, this is the controls new offset transform.
So when we're going to use this as our aim control, so as we move it left and right,
up and down, we want our turret and our turret body to be pointing towards it.
So with that control selected, I'm going to pop open target space here.
Oh, whoops, not under secondary.
Target space here just under the primary heading and input that as our control.
And when we connect up the logic, if I just grab our sequence node here, hit compile,
what we'll hopefully see is that when we move it left and right, our control, which is controlling
the main body of the gun is actually rotating left and right with it.
And if we move it up and down, forwards and backwards, we're not getting any other movement.
There is a little bit just because it's off axis now.
But if I compile that, move it up and down, we don't get anything there.
Move it backwards and forwards.
We don't get anything there.
And that's just because we've set up the limits on this control already.
So we don't have to do anything extra with the bones to sort of clamp their rotation.
We're relying on the settings of these controls to do all of that for us.
Now let's set up the rotation for the actual gun turret itself.
I'm just going to bring this down here a little bit so we have enough space.
And drag off here, search for an aim node once more.
And our target is going to be the same control.
And under the target and axis, this time we're going to leave the settings as they are.
And selecting our, if I just compile that to make sure it's at zero,
selecting our main gun control, that's going to be what we want to use to aim
towards this cannon aim control.
So now if I move this left and right, we have the movement on the turret body.
And if I move it up and down, we should have the movement from the main gun.
And again, that's locked in terms of how much it can rotate.
Because of the settings that we created, or the values that we set up,
should I say, for that control itself.
So you could pin this somewhere in the world, and then as the rest of the mech is moving around,
it would always track this one location.
Or you know the mech could be standing still, and you could be moving this location,
unlocking it onto some sort of target that it's trying to aim and fire at.
Now one thing to note is that it's going to override the control of the turret base and the main gun controls.
But you could do something like set up a switch that would toggle between these two different control types,
depending on which one you'd like to use.